Steve Jobs went from having his birth
parents give him up for adoption and
being a college dropout to co-founding
Apple I'm being recognized as one of the
most influential entrepreneurs of all
time Steve Wozniak sold is HB 65
calculator for $500 and Steve Jobs sold
his VW bus for 750 dollars to buy
supplies to lunch he usually went to
work wearing a black long-sleeve
turtleneck Levi's 501 blue jeans and New
Balance sneakers his choice was inspired
by an applied mathematics professor at
Brown University he liked the idea of
having a uniform for himself because it
was convenient and it gave him a
signature style the motivation watched
top 10 with believe nation what's that
believe nation it's Evan I believe in
you and this channel is designed to be
part of your daily success routine so
let's get your motivation to attend
here's my take on Steve Jobs as top 10
Rose success vol 3 also if you want to
know what Steve Jobs and other
successful entrepreneurs have to say
about building unstoppable confidence
check out my 250 for confidence series
where every day for the next 254 days I
will send you a morning video for free
to help you build your confidence the
link to join is in the description below
what separates the successful
entrepreneurs from the non successful
ones is pure perseverance
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one work with the best I've noticed
something in my life which is the people
that are really good want to work with
the best people they can find hopefully
people that are even better than them
you know I mean that's my view of things
as if if you work with people that
aren't as good as you then you know you
become a country of midgets if you work
with people that are better than you
then you really grow rule number two be
customer driven we've also had a lot of
requests from companies to port next
step to other platforms and we're
talking to some of those companies right
now now son we got a lot of requests
from son customers to port next step to
sons a lot of them are saying look we we
may not want to buy them anymore but we
already bought 500 and we go and throw
em in the bay so can we put your
software them cuz sons falling behind in
software now son says they'd rather
stick needles in their eyes than help us
do this that's a quote
and so we're evaluating right now which
will be worse for Sun if we poured it or
if we don't port it
and since we're fairly since we're
fairly customer driven we'll probably
end up doing what the customers asked us
to do because we want to make them happy
well there were three focus on quality a
group of people that do not use quality
in their marketing are the Japanese you
never see them using quality in their
marketing it's only the American
companies that do and yet if you ask
people on the street which products have
the best reputation for quality they
will tell you the Japanese products now
why is that how could that be the answer
is because customers don't form their
opinions on quality from marketing they
don't form their opinions on quality
from who won the the Deming award or who
won the Baldrige award they form their
opinions on quality from their own
experience with the products or the
services and so one can spend enormous
amounts of money on quality one can win
every quality where there is and yet if
your products don't live up to it
customers will not keep that opinion for
long in their minds and so I think where
we have to start is with our products
and our services not with our marketing
department and we need to get back to
the basics and go improve our products
and services
now again quality isn't just the product
or the service it's having the right
product you know knowing where the
markets going and having the most
innovative products is just as much a
part of quality as the quality of the
construction of the product when you
have it rule number four stay focused on
your mission
[Music]
did it hurt to have your people the
people who you know love you boo you
like that is this sea huh I didn't know
this was people People magazine no well
this is this is there is well I'd like
I'd like no I got you you brought it up
yourself you said emotion you know
emotionally you know a different yeah no
I mean I I don't feel my job is to win a
popularity contest right now and I feel
my job is to help the team at Apple do
the right things to turn this company
around so that it can really prosper
again and and I think that's gonna
happen and if something you know some
people I mean the markets we're talking
markets now that are so large that
there's you know someone or some group
of people that aren't gonna like just
about anything we do but my job's not to
win a popularity contest rule number
five don't compromise it seems like all
the good people I really want to hire it
seems to take me a year to hire them and
it's always been that way even at Apple
some of the best technical people or
whoever it always seem to take me like a
year to pry them out of HP or wherever
it took me it took me over a year to
high mining mike has the award you're
about a year and a half and they're all
worth it what happens is I usually meet
somebody that is really good I think is
very very good and you can't get them
and then you go try to find other people
and you know nobody measures up you know
when you meet somebody that good just
you always compare them this one person
you know you're gonna be settling for
second best if you compromise I've
always found it best not to compromise
and rule number six appreciate your team
I want you all to go into one of our
retail stores in the next 810 weeks and
just give one of the Apple retail store
employees a hug
a candid Steve Jobs my theory of of
management is is the Beatles deflecting
credit for Apple's success by citing his
favorite band together they they helped
amplify each other's really good
tendencies and that's true of any team
and we got a really great team here at
Apple thanking them for their work on
the iPhone the day before its release
and I think everybody who's worked on
iPhone and made those sacrifices is
gonna feel that it's been worth it
rule number seven do write things
somebody taught me a long time ago a
very valuable lesson which is if you do
the right things on the top line the
bottom line will follow and what they
meant by that was if you get the right
strategy if you have the right people
and if you have the right culture
culture at your company you'll do the
right products you'll do the right
marketing you'll do the right things
logistically in a manufacturing and
distribution and if you do all those
things right the bottom line will follow
rule number eight create a competitive
advantage we came up with the software
called next step which lets you build
apps five to ten times faster than
anything anyone has ever seen and after
you build them they're deployable and
usable by mere mortals because it's
really easy to use this computer in any
manner and you can interoperate your
custom apps seamlessly with a bunch of
off-the-shelf productivity apps so we go
to these companies that use Suns and
take two years to write their apps or
thinking about using sense and they can
write their apps in about 90 days on the
next now if you're on Wall Street and
you can write you can create a new
product in ninety days versus your
competitor in two years that's eight new
products you can field for there every
one and you can start to see the
competitive advantage that can be
created this way now we had no idea that
we were any good at this when we started
next a lot of times you don't know what
your competitive advantage is when you
launch a new product when we did the
Macintosh we never anticipated desktop
publishing when we created the Mac
sounds funny because that turned out to
be the max compelling advantage right
the thing that it did not one and a half
or two times better than everything else
but you know four or five times better
than anything else where you had to have
one we never anticipated it we
anticipated bitmap displays and laser
printers but we never thought about
PageMaker that whole industry really
coming down to the desktop maybe we
weren't smart enough but we were smart
enough to see it start to happen nine to
twelve months later and we changed our
entire marketing and business strategy
to focus on desktop publishing and it
became the Trojan horse that eventually
got the Mac into corporate America where
it could show its owners all the other
wonderful things you could do likewise
when we created next step this
revolutionary object-oriented software
that we have our target customer coming
from the PC world where shrink-wrap apps
were king was Lotus in a dough being
WordPerfect in all the shrink-wrap apps
developers and the purpose was to let
them create their apps 5 to 10 times
faster these shrink-wrapped apps and it
worked we have a ton of shrink-wrapped
apps now on Best of Breed in almost
every category but it wasn't till early
and 91 early last year little over a
year ago that some really big companies
came to us and said you don't understand
what you've got the same software that
allows Lotus to create their apps 5 to
10 times faster is letting us build our
in-house mission-critical apps 5 to 10
times faster and this is the biggest
problem we've had this is a huge problem
for every big company and almost all
medium-sized companies and you have the
solution in your hands and you dummies
don't even know it and it took him about
three months before we finally heard it
and in last summer we changed our whole
sales and marketing strategy around to
focus on that it's taken off like a
rocket and we grew about 4x last year
and probably grow about 2x this year and
our customer list is is now very very
strong and growing like crazy we just
got back from spending a few days in DC
and in New York and we're talking to
customers we only dreamed of talking to
a year ago rule number nine be your own
audience Apple was a very classic
Silicon Valley startup in the sense that
Steve Wozniak and my partner both worked
for hewlett-packard matter of fact woz
was still working there when we started
Apple and hewlett-packard was the
genesis of of not just the concept of
starting your own company but and of
course it was the primary role model in
the valley but it was also the ethics or
the ethical basis of how you wanted to
build your company a company that was
based on values not based on just making
money and HP had had the HP way and they
had a list of their values and the first
one was we need to make a profit or else
we can't keep this company going but
after that they got into how they wanted
to treat individuals and conduct their
corporate life and it was it's very
idealistic in my opinion so we were we
were very much influenced by that the
second thing that made us very very
typical in a way was that we were
building a product that we ourselves
were the customer for we were building
something we wanted ourselves just like
Hewlett and Packard started building
test equipment and equipment for
engineers well they were engineers so
they they could in essence do the
marketing they could figure out what an
engineer might want in a product as well
as designing we wanted a computer and we
knew exactly what we wanted in a
computer so we could do the marketing as
well as the engineering of that product
this changed later as we started selling
to people that were different than us
but certainly in the first several years
of Apple we were selling the people that
were just like us and a lot of Silicon
Valley companies have started that way
and it's it's you know it's very
efficient and I think it works quite
well and rule number 10 the last one
before a very special bonus clip is have
fun we're introducing a revolutionary
new product for your iPod Sox they're
really cool actually
and know it like that they keep your
ipod warm on cold days they protect it
and they give you a little more
personality
good morning yes I'd like to order 4,000
lattes to go please no it's just kidding
wrong number thank you okay clicker is
not working all right
there's scrambling backstage right now
it is magical I know it because I got
this email I was sitting in a cafe with
my iPad and you've got a girl interested
in
I'm working pretty hard and so there are
a lot of people but I'm one of them my
cars they're pretty early and it's in
the parking lot pretty late and on
weekends so and I value my family time a
lot so I I'm pretty committed to this
and seeing Apple turn around the company
I mean it's I started the company with
Steve Wozniak in my parent's garage you
know 20 years ago and over 22 years ago
and so there's a definite place in my
heart for this I'm drawing a salary if I
think $1 per year so I hope I'm not
burdening the shareholders too much and
and I'm I very much want to see Apple
get turned around and I think it's gonna
so I I don't know how much more
committed I could be if people need
these symbols well maybe that'll happen
I don't know but but you know my answer
to them is I don't know how I could be
working any harder and raise your
standard Apple at the core its core
value is that that people need passion
and not one drop of most self-worth
depends on your it's suppose to mean
if you want more Steve Jobs check the
top 10 rules vol 2 that I made on him
the link is right there next to me I
think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there did Leonardo have a guy off to the
side that was thinking 5 years out in
the future what he would paint or the
technology he would use to paint it of
course not